nos confrères de rmc l'ont annoncé
aujourd'hui les dirigeants du psg aurait
déjà retenu deux dossiers pour
accueillir son futur centre
d'entraînement saint germain en laye
sites historiques et saint quentin en
yvelines bernard tabary bonsoir vous
êtes en ligne avec nous président de la
base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
bonsoir à vous vous portez donc ce
dossier le camp des loges qui se
rapproche du vélodrome peut-être le
centre d'entraînement du psg à deux pas
du temple du cyclisme en en france cette
information cette place de finaliste de
saint quentin en yvelines est ce que la
direction du paris saint germain vous
l'a confirmé aujourd'hui est ce que vous
les avez eu en ligne aujourd'hui
alors ça veut dire que vous ne savez pas
encore mais c'est de mauvaise augure ça
veut dire que cette information ce ne
serait pas sur vous la prenez en tout
cas comme sûrs de votre côté comme
acquise
le dossier véritablement de saint
germain en laye qui reste ultra favori
c'est ce qu'on peut lire un petit peu
partout le conseil général des yvelines
le maire de paris également le
soutiennent est ce que vous êtes déçu
que bertrand delanoë ne vous soutiennent
pas ne soit pas avec saint quentin en
yvelines
de quels soutiens justement quels sont
les points forts de ce dossier quels
sont les quels sont les soutiens
justement dont vous disposez quand on
voit qu'en face il ya le justement sur
le dossier de saint germain et le
conseil général ya le maire de paris
également quels sont vos soutiens
et le président de la région il est
disponible en
accompagner
pour la visite
je fais
un ministre aussi
maintenant
j'ai tout à fait
chacun choisit son camp peut-être en
tout cas le psg à saint quentin en
yvelines
il y aurait eu en tout cas une avancée
puisque les dirigeants auraient retenu
vous nous l'avez dit ne s'étaient pas
confirmés vous n'avez pas eu
confirmation de cette information on
imagine que pour arriver dans les
prochaines heures en tout cas d'ici à la
fin de la semaine le dossier aurait été
retenu celui de saint quentin en
yvelines celui de saint germain en laye
pour installer le futur camp des loges
merci bernard tabary d'avoir été en
ligne avec nous pour pour repréciser ces
informations qui sont tombés aujourd'hui
merci à vous